morning on stage, have the best day of your life.
How we doing tonight?
We're doing okay?
Hey, it's great to see you Thanks so much for being here.
It's been an amazing evening already I just have this sense like in my gut like the core of my being that God really wants to do something Here in the room tonight like we're not just here to play Christian games We want to meet with the living God.
We believe that he has spoken through his word and so I am a
So excited that you're here truly and I'm so excited that you're tuning in wherever it is you are if you're tuning in online with us right now like We say this here and you've probably heard me say it before if you tuned in with us But we truly believe like God can meet with anybody anywhere at any time
whenever he so chooses, and that includes you.
So thanks for being a part of what God is doing here at the porch.
We think he has something special in store for you.
Special shout out to all of our porch live locations.
Yeah, we love those guys that are out there across the nation, but particularly porch live Scottsdale in the wonderful state of Arizona.
We love them, porch live Boise, which is awesome.
Things are probably getting cold up north and then porch live Fresno.
We love all of our porch live locations.
So which I'll give it up for them real fast to be amazing.
Well hey, several weeks ago, I got to do something that I thought I never would.
I got to co-pilot a private jet.
Now admittedly, co-pilot is probably a little bit of a strong word because I know nothing about flying an airplane.
And yet, for all intents and purposes, that's essentially what I was doing minus any of the actual control of the aircraft.
Like I was sitting in the cockpit of this plane and I was experiencing everything that the pilot was himself.
Like I'm sitting right there and the plane steering wheel is like coming up through my legs and I can hold on to that thing.
And then there's this dash in front of me and all these meters and lights and different kinds of readings
that I cannot make any kind of sense of it.
They're all right there in front of me.
I got the headphones on so I could hear everything that air traffic control is saying to us.
And I looked to my left and there he is, the pilot himself.
Like this thing was awesome.
I'd never experienced anything like it.
And yet the reason it was so great wasn't just because I'd never been on a plane before.
I'd been on a plane before.
Like I've ridden on the big commercial airplanes.
I grew up.
My granddad, he flew a little prop plane.
And so I'd been in that sort of situation before.
But I had never been
in the cockpit of a private jet.
And so being in that environment changed everything for me because the views are a little bit different from up there.
You know what I'm saying?
Like I'm sitting there and I'm not looking out the side view mirror.
I'm looking out the front windshield and I'm seeing everything that's happening.
And so we're sitting there and we pull out onto the runway and we kind of line up and
We get clearance from air traffic control to go for it.
And so next thing you know, we're like a bullet, like racing down this runway and the lines in front of us are speeding by.
And this jet is, it is accelerating so fast.
It was the coolest experience.
And next thing you know, he gently lifts us off the ground.
It was the moment I'd been waiting for.
And as we do, like rain kind of begins to pelt our windshield because it was sort of a dreary day.
And next thing you know, we get up into the clouds.
And it's kind of a disorienting experience because we're in these clouds and we can't see anything.
All we can see is the rain.
on the front windshield until we broke through the clouds and we reached our cruising altitude.
And as we went from a pitched ascent to a flattened cruising altitude, we found ourselves facing the most beautiful of settings.
I mean, this was the closest to heaven that I'd ever seen before, you know what I'm saying?
I am looking at white clouds beneath us
kind of billowing across like bubble wrap.
And then as you're looking around, you can see out over to my right this massive storm cell and lightning cracking within it.
And then as I look over to my left, you can see blue where there was no blue before.
Like this was the most amazing kind of scene.
And as I'm sitting there and I'm taking it all in, I start to pepper the pilot with my personal list of 20 questions because this is the closest thing to flying I'm ever gonna get.
And so I've got a bunch of things that I want to figure out.
And as he's answering all of them, he said something that really stuck with me so much so
I wrote it down on my notes because I wanted to make sure I could share it with you.
He said, from the ground, it feels like the weather is always changing.
But from up here, we know the sun is always shining.
And as he said that at 30,000 feet, I thought of you, porch.
You were on my mind as I flew in the cockpit of this plane because I thought that's not just true to pilots.
That's true to you and me.
Like from many of you here, it feels like the weather in your world is always changing.
Like one minute, the weather might be beautiful.
And the next thing you know, it feels like a storm is shaking your reality.
And then you're next slipping into this sort of apathetic sort of moody gray weather weather sort of situation.
And yet though the weather may always feel like it's changing,
in your world, you can be confident that the sun is still shining.
It all depends on your perspective, however.
That's how you're able to discern the difference.
Like that pilot, you've got to get up to an altitude where you can see things as they actually are.
You've got to get up to God's altitude.
You've got to see from his perspective
And as you do, you're able to make sense of whatever it is you're truly feeling in life.
That's what we've been trying to do in this series.
Like if you're here for the very first time, we've been journey through a series called 2020 where we're trying to put your mental health into perspective.
And the way that we've been doing it is we've been doing it through the book of Psalms.
The reason why we've been in the book of Psalms is, the book of Psalms is sort of, it reads kind of like your personal diary.
Not that you have a personal diary, but maybe you had a personal diary.
It reads like that though.
It's full of raw emotion, brutal honesty, like impassioned pleas.
That's the way the Psalms
read out.
It's like your diary in the sense that it is 100% full of emotion.
And yet the Psalms is unlike your diary in that it is also 100% full of truth.
That's why it's the perfect place to process a proper perspective when it comes to our mental and emotional health because we can feel all of our feelings and yet we can bring those things as the psalmist do to God's truth.
and he can speak into them, inform them, and ultimately shape the way that we walk through this world.
And so what we're doing over the course of the series is we're really framing around the top five mental health challenges, most common amongst Americans today.
The first week was all about depression, the second week was all about anxiety, and tonight we're gonna be talking about addiction, addiction and indulgence.
And to unpack it, we're gonna be looking at Psalm 141.
So if you've got a Bible, you can turn with me there.
Psalm 141, while you're doing that, let me just say this because it's important to be said week after week.
We know our depth up here.
Like I'm not a doctor, there's no part of me that is trying to diagnose what it is you're dealing with.
Like I feel very comfortable and confident from the scripture to speak into a variety of situational sorts of circumstances.
Many of you here, you may find yourself beyond the bounds of a situational type of mental health challenge.
You might be facing something that is clinical.
Instead, if that's you, what I want you to know is the truth of God's word will be vital for your healing.
But that doesn't mean it's mutually exclusive to the treatment plan or recommendations made by your doctor, like the scripture and your prescription.
they can work in partnership together.
They can be a part of your healing journey.
And I also want to say that if you're here tonight and you would consider yourself an addict, maybe you've been diagnosed as such or maybe yourself diagnosed as such, I just want you to hear, nowhere in this message are you going to hear me say, you just need to stop that because that would imply that you have the strength to overcome your addiction all on your own.
And the truth is,
Many addicts do not have the strength to do that.
Instead, they need to rely on the strength of others.
And so I want to stand before you right now.
And if that's you, I just want to plead with you.
Would you let us be strong for you?
Would you give us the permission to jump into whatever it is you're dealing with by visiting with us at the end of the night?
You don't have to necessarily come down front.
You can find anybody in a black shirt and a lanyard and you can just grab them by the hand and they'll know like, okay, that means that I probably need to visit with you and private pull you over and introduce you to someone on staff, but we're really serious about helping you make good strides when it comes to the topic of your addiction.
Now, with all of that said,
How do we get a proper perspective on addiction, on indulgence?
Well, first and foremost, we have to understand the problem of it.
That's where we've begun all of these talks.
That's where we're beginning here tonight.
We need to understand that addiction is a bigger deal in danger than most of us realize.
So if you've been tracking the headlines and you may already know this, but in case you haven't, we are, according to many researchers facing what they're calling an addiction crisis.
According to Shatterproof, one of the leading nonprofit organizations that's committed to ending addiction in our country.
Hear this.
Nearly 49 million Americans, I repeat, nearly 49 million Americans ages 12 or older had a substance use addiction in the past year.
Meaning they rely on things like
like alcohol and cannabis and cocaine and methamphetamine and opioids, they rely on all manner of different substances to provide them the kind of comfort they cannot find elsewhere.
To put that into perspective for you, because 49 million may feel a little bit ethereal, that means nearly one in six people are living in substance dependence today.
Making it likely that you and I will encounter someone that either has or will have some sort of substance use disorder in their life.
Now you may be sitting here and thinking to yourself, but Kyle and I don't struggle with that.
So this doesn't feel relevant to me at all.
Well, before you tune me out, that's only half of what we're discussing tonight because what you need to also know is that while there is substance use addiction, there's also something else called behavioral addiction.
Track with me here because this one's far more prevalent.
Behavioral addiction is like substance addiction, except it's not being addicted to drugs or alcohol.
Instead, the individual is addicted to a particular behavior in the feelings that are evoked from that behavior that lead them to a place where they lack self-control.
So see if you identify potentially.
Behavioral addiction can include things like social media, pornography, cell phone use, video gaming, workaholism, food,
Compulsive shopping, exercise, who would have thought?
Self-harm and gambling.
All of these things can be damaging to your mental health.
Now, why do I share all that with you?
Some of you are sitting here like, dude, just get into Psalm 141.
We're going to.
Just bear with me.
It's important for us to understand this warning that none of us are as safe as we think we are when it comes to the topic of addiction.
Do you think anybody ever intends to enslave themselves to some sort of indulgence?
No, of course they don't.
Nobody is ever intending.
You know what?
I do think I'll be an alcoholic.
That sounds like a nice way of living.
Nobody is intending to do that.
And we laugh, and yet the reality is this thing comes for all of us in a way where it doesn't just suddenly show up instead it gradually creeps in.
It's like the free app on your phone that you downloaded because, ah,
Nothing's harmless and yet it's draining your battery.
It's stealing your data.
It's waking you up at two in the morning.
Like that's what's happening.
It's creeped into your life under the premise.
It is harmless and yet it's actually come to disrupt everything about your reality.
And so we've got to know what do we do with it?
Like how do we actually move away from what we're going to get to that, but what we have to understand first and foremost and David actually shares this with us is an addiction.
It takes root because it appeals to your reward system.
A really simple way of understanding that is it feels good to be bad.
That's what happens.
So think of it like this.
Not everyone that drinks doom scrolls and watches pornography does it because they just want to be a really addicted individual.
No, they do it because they're trying to reduce stress, loneliness, discomfort.
A lot of people that work in high stress, fast paced corporate environments, they will find themselves using things like alcohol and prescription medication and stimulants because they want to
because they ultimately know what it takes to keep up in this environment.
They're not doing it because, well, that's going to make mom proud.
Instead, they're doing it because that's the price they have to pay to be productive.
Any procrastinators in the room?
Why are you a procrastinator?
Is it just because you want everybody to be waiting on you?
No.
Is it because you love to watch the world burn?
Some of you.
But really, the reason so many of you are procrastinators is because you're a perfectionist.
And so you're trying to reduce the anxiety and the frustrations you feel about completing a task that is less than the standard you actually want to achieve.
Do you see how it works?
It feels good, leaves you rewarded to do bad.
And we see David wrestling with that very reality in Psalm 141.
Now, as we set this passage up, what you need to know is the context of it is debated.
We don't necessarily know
for certain what the situation around David is.
And yet as we read through it, you can sort of pick out some context clues to help you guess where he may be and what may be happening.
Scholars, they land in one of two places.
They either think that he is being pursued by King Saul in his youth or King Absalom following his kingship.
And what you need to know is neither one of them ultimately really matter because what we can understand is they are both marked by a similar set of circumstances.
The guy's being hunted down.
Tough day at the office, right?
Like he's being hunted down.
He's being pursued by attackers.
His life is on the line.
And so what we see him say in the middle of that entire situation in verse three, he says, set a guard, O Lord, over my mouth.
Keep watch over the door of my lips.
Do not let my heart incline to any evil to busy myself with wicked deeds and company with men who work iniquity and let me not eat of their delicacies.
Do you hear the struggle in his voice?
What David is saying right here is he saying, I want to sin.
Like I want to get back.
I want to dish back whatever has been dished out to me.
Like I want to give them a dose of their own medicine.
They're trying to pursue me and take me out.
I want to pursue them and I want to take them out.
God, that's what I want to do.
I'm praying to you because I actually want to sin.
And so God, what I'm asking is that you would guard me from myself.
That's what he's articulating right here.
The problem of his indulgence is he wants to retaliate.
He wants to indulge an evil desire against those that have been evil against him.
And the way that he says, God, would you guard me is threefold.
He asks God, would you guard my mouth?
Would you guard my heart?
And would you guard my desire?
Why is it threefold?
Because that's the way it works.
Remember, indulgence creeps in.
It doesn't just show up.
It gradually takes hold.
And so it often begins with our words.
He says, keep watch over the door of my lips.
Why does he start there?
Watch over my mouth, God, because what we say out loud, what we feel inside is giving our feelings and opportunity to become a legitimized to the point that we identify with them.
So I'll give you an example of this.
I thought it was fascinating a year ago during the Paris Olympics.
Olympians were regularly asked by reporters, are you nervous?
And they would regularly reply, no, I'm excited.
which is fascinating why, because both nervousness and excitement are similar in terms of the physical sensation they produce.
Gives you clammy hands and a sweaty brow and a racing heart, like that's what ultimately nervousness and excitement both do.
And yet what these Olympians are saying is that they want to positively identify with that emotion as opposed to negatively identify with that emotion.
So they're not willing to,
Subscribe to the way the reporter is saying it.
Instead, they want to reframe it so they identify with it instead.
They know what I say is what I'm going to become.
And so I don't want to be nervous.
I want to be excited.
Makes sense.
That's why you have to start with your words.
David is saying in reference to something similar we see in the book of James.
We're not going to read this specific passage.
You can go look at his James 3, 3, 3, 5, but we learn that the power of the tongue is extreme.
It's like a bit in the mouth of a horse.
It's like a rudder on the tail of a ship.
It's like a fire that can set the whole forest ablaze.
Like it has great power to change the whole of something.
So too does your mouth have that kind of power.
but it doesn't stop there.
It doesn't just affect your words, it affects your deeds.
He says, do not let my heart incline to any evil.
In the West, when we read the word heart, we think Valentine's Day and the things that I feel, butterflies inside, love for other people.
You know, like we think it's all about emotion.
And yet what we know is the heart in the ancient Near Eastern mind is not about emotion as much as it is about action.
It's the seed of the will.
which is basically the place from which you make decisions in life.
And so David is saying here, he's like, hey, I don't just feel temptation to slander my enemies, to use my mouth, to tear them down.
I also feel the urge to retaliate against him, to take swift action, to dish back what they've dished to me.
But he doesn't just stop there.
Begins with his words, it moves to his deeds, and then it creeps into his desire.
He says, let me not eat of their delicacies.
It's a really important part of the verse because it tells us something important about the way that sin works.
Sin doesn't just want you to do evil.
Sin wants you to delight in evil.
It wants you to love it.
That's why it feels bad or it feels good to do something bad.
Remember, ultimately, it wants to appeal to your
pleasure.
It's a delicacy.
It's a delight to the taste, which is really important because it teaches us something we need to understand about indulgence or temptation or addiction ultimately.
We need to know it's rarely about the substance.
Instead, it's about what the substance represents.
What I mean by that is David was not just
intent to take these guys out.
He was willing to do that if it afforded him peace from his anxiety, freedom from their pursuit, in hope of a brand new future.
See how that works.
He's not just focused on the substance.
He's focused on what the substance represents.
And that's the way it works for everybody.
Like whether it's behavioral or it is substance, pornography, excessive shopping,
eating disorders, opioid addiction, it doesn't matter, across the range of it all.
It's never about the substance, about what the substance represents.
Oh, well, that gives me relief.
Well, that provides me comfortable.
I feel a sense of belonging whenever I do that.
I get freedom whenever I find myself actually participating in that activity.
I get validation.
I matter whenever I do that.
See how it works?
But what if I could, what if I told you?
You could find all of that and more without the substance.
What if I told you there was a way to feel good by doing good?
What if I told you there was a way to change your perspective altogether?
Well, that's what the rest of Psalm 141 is all about.
And that's what we're going to talk about because if your problem is indulgence, your perspective can be self-control.
Just like David says,
And to show you how that happens, I'm going to give you four ways to control your cravings moving forward.
And let me be very clear.
This is for the addict in the room, but this is for all of us in the room because it never begins at addiction.
It starts at temptation and we have to deal with that.
So here we go.
Verse one, starting at the beginning of the passage, says, Oh Lord, I call upon you, hasten to me.
Give ear to my voice when I call to you.
Let my prayer be counted as incense before you in the lifting up of my hands as the evening sacrifice.
So the first thing you need to know if you want to control your cravings is you pray before you do anything else.
You pray before you do anything else, which probably feels classically Christian to you.
You're like, you should pray first.
What a typical recommendation from the pastor.
Just bear with me for a minute because I understand you're probably sitting there thinking like okay, like I'll write this one down But I'm really interested in whatever he's gonna say next but this one matters because it sets up everything from here
Like it's not just that he's praying.
Yes, you need to know what he's doing, but you need to know how he's doing it.
How does he do it?
If you read it, it says he hastens, he offers like incense, he calls, he lifts his hands.
Do you see that?
Like there's an earnestness, there's a seriousness, there's an urgency, there's an intensity to the way that he's praying.
He is looking at his situation and he's not thinking to himself, this is the first step in the Christian formula for self-control.
No, he's not doing that.
He's looking at it and he is making a 911 call to heaven.
He is dialing up God and he is saying, I need help.
Like I'm facing something that is ultimately alluring to me and alluring of me is something that I don't want to do.
Like God, I'm being chased down and I'm tired of it.
Like I want to indulge the evil desire I have.
I want to give into the negative attitude that I'm feeling.
God, I need you to help me.
He knows the temptation he's facing is so strong.
And so he prays because God is stronger.
That's why you pray.
You realize, I'm not strong enough.
God is instead.
That's where he starts.
He starts by coming to God.
So let me ask you, when you face temptation, where do you turn first?
Like whenever you sense yourself tempted with sexual desire, do you turn to God first?
Or do you turn to your explore page?
And just start scrolling because, well, man, that's not porn.
When in reality, it's just a slippery slope.
It's going to move you right into that, which you want to avoid.
Like whenever you feel in yourself, a temptation to just numb out, like, do you turn first to God?
Or do you turn to some kind of mindless entertainment?
Scrolling, shopping, eating, gaming, whatever it may be.
Maybe it's not that, maybe whenever you're tempted by insecurity.
Do you turn first to God or do you turn to admit how much money am I actually making or what kind of body am I actually building or how many followers am I accumulating?
Like what is it for you?
It could be any manner of things.
There's just three examples.
There are so many more examples that I could give, but the point nevertheless remains.
If you're turning some other place than God, you are turning to the wrong place.
And I want to love you enough to just say that.
There's no other place where you will find the strength to overcome your temptation than if you turn first and foremost to God.
How do I know that?
Because that's what Jesus said.
He taught this to his own disciples in that moment of greatest temptation in the Garden of Gethsemane.
He looked at Peter, James, and John, and he said this in Matthew 2641, he said, watch and pray.
that you may not enter into temptation.
The spirit indeed is willing, but the flesh is weak.
Doesn't that just resonate with so many of you?
That resonates with me.
Like, watch and pray why.
The spirit is willing.
Like, I don't want to sin God, but the flesh is weak.
You don't have the strength.
to make it through this temptation.
But if you seek God, therein you'll find the strength you need for your deliverance.
That's the first thing you gotta know, but you gotta come to him.
Let me ask you, I wasn't playing on saying this, but I think it's important.
What if you prayed as hard before the sin as you pray after the sin?
What would that look like?
What would it look like for you to labor and prayer before as opposed to seek forgiveness following?
I bet that would look radically different for so many of us.
And listen, I get it.
Some of you are sitting here like, try that, doesn't work.
Listen, I've tried that, didn't work.
You wanna know why it didn't work?
Because I put up a haphazard prayer.
It wasn't that God didn't show up after I prayed.
I didn't show up when I prayed.
I was like, God, this is gonna be a tempting moment.
Would you please meet me in it?
Please deliver me, Lord, I love you.
And it made no difference, why?
because I wasn't really looking for a difference.
I wasn't really seeking God.
What would it look like for you to pray with the kind of earnestness and seriousness that David did?
And listen, I'm not saying prayers easy, but what I am saying is sometimes you gotta pray until you pray.
That's an old Puritan expression, and I think it is so true to so many of us.
Like, what does prayer do?
It's not getting God on board with your agenda, it's you getting on board with God's agenda.
And so sometimes if your heart feels cold, the first place you need to go is you just need to start praying to them.
Like that's where you need, you need to go into the closet and you need to hit your knees and you need to start lifting up words and you need to trust the fact that they're not just rebounding off the ceiling.
They're somehow by God's grace, making their way all the way to heaven's throne.
That's what's happening in that moment.
It's supernatural.
It's the most supernatural of spiritual disciplines.
What would it look like?
You feel like you have
No power in the face of your sin.
You want to know where powerlessness comes from?
It comes from prayerlessness.
So you pray.
You pray before you do anything else.
You've got to come do them.
That's the first thing.
Let's keep going.
We're going to go back to verse three.
He says, Set a guard, O Lord, over my mouth.
Keep watch over the door of my lips.
Do not let my heart incline to any evil to busy myself with wicked deeds and the company with men who work iniquity.
And let me not eat of their delicacies.
The second thing you need to know if you want to control your cravings is don't justify bad decisions.
Don't justify bad decisions.
I love it.
We already looked at these verses.
David is literally saying in this moment, like, I want to sin and yet the amazing thing is in the face of his desire, he does not make up any justification.
He doesn't look at God and be like, oh God, yeah, you remember that guy Goliath?
Yeah, I was there for that one.
No one else was willing to do it, but I stepped up and I did it.
You owe me this, God.
He doesn't come up with that kind of excuse.
He doesn't look at God and say, uh, did you forget?
Like you were the one that anointed me.
Like I didn't ask for this, but you chose me to be the king of Israel.
And now I'm out here in the wilderness.
I'm running for my life.
What's it going to look like for you to help me out for once?
He doesn't come up with all of these justifications and excuses.
I love that he doesn't.
And yet I'm also convicted by the reality that we do this all the time.
We do come up with justifications for our sin.
Like we don't just, like we do, we give ourselves way too much credit.
We'll say things like, well, I deserve this God.
You know how hard I've been working?
How fast I've been going?
Like everybody needs something for me.
What about what I need God?
Like I need a break.
I need a breath.
I need to catch an hour all to myself, God, I need this.
I deserve this.
I've earned this.
I've worked hard for this, God.
I deserve whatever it is that I'm craving.
Maybe it's not that.
Maybe it's, but this is only going to happen once.
It's just one drink, but God, my birthday, one comes around one time a year.
I've been saving up.
It's time to spend a little bit on myself.
my friends like we haven't gotten together in forever and this is the one time we're all going to get together and so just this once like I'm gonna bend the rules a little bit I might make some compromising decisions who knows like we might get a little crazy maybe it's not that maybe instead it's well who's it gonna hurt like who's it gonna hurt for me to stay up all night watching TV like no one staying up and being impacted that by that but me or who's it gonna hurt if I if I
make sexual advances via some sort of dating app.
Like, I don't know them, they don't know me, and who knows?
Like, maybe I'll hit one and it'll go well.
Maybe it's not that.
Like, maybe it's my body.
Like, God, I'm not hurting anybody when I hurt myself.
So why does it matter if I do this, if it only impacts me?
Maybe it's not that.
Maybe your excuse instead is it's just not that big of a deal.
Christians love this one.
I'm not drunk.
I'm just a little tipsy.
Maybe it's not,
that maybe instead it's God I'm staying sexually pure but part of the way that I pursue my personal purity is I've got a masturbate like how else am I going to get a sexual outlet God like I can't be single forever and if you're gonna call me to be single you're not gonna give me anybody to marry then I guess this is the only way that I'm gonna be able to process these sort of emotions maybe it's not that maybe it's God I'm not hurting my witness like it's not that big of a deal I'm not hurting my witness if everybody around me is saved oh my god
We justify our sin, our indulgences, and our addiction all the time.
Simply because it feels good to do bad things.
You know what God has to say about that?
He says, in Galatians 6, do not be deceived.
I'm not mocked.
For whatever one sows,
That will he also reap?
For the one who sows his own flesh will from the flesh reap corruption, but the one who sows to the spirit will from the spirit reap eternal life.
What's that passage saying?
It's saying you cultivate whatever you tolerate.
You cultivate whatever you tolerate.
It's like whatever sin it is you're tolerating.
That is the sin that you're cultivating.
So what are you tolerating?
Maybe it seems harmless right now, but I guarantee you it will not be harmless later on.
I remember talking to a friend of mine.
It was right after I made the switch from college ministry and to young adult ministry.
And he said something that really stuck with me.
It resonated to this day.
He was like, dude, young adult ministry is awesome.
You're going to love it.
It's amazing.
But there's something you need to be aware of.
In college ministry, you see the seeds of sin.
But in young adult ministry, you see the fruit of sin.
Why is that?
Because if sin goes untamed, sin runs wild.
It must be addressed, which is why I am pleading with you tonight to do something about it.
Like I am begging you, don't just justify the struggle, mortify the struggle, put it to death, put it down.
Nothing likes to die in this life.
Your sin doesn't either, and yet I'm praying you would do something about it.
Gosh, I'm praying you would do something about it.
I'm running out of time, but I just feel the need to keep pushing into you.
So not just indulge a bunch of religious activity, but to literally lean into the spiritual reality that you have an enemy.
It doesn't want you to do well.
He doesn't want you to experience life.
He doesn't want you to find joy.
And so he will bait you, lure you, take you into other places, promising you you'll find it there when in reality he knows it's not over there at all.
Do something about it.
Confess your sin.
Get some friends.
Wage war.
Strengthen your weak knees.
Like go to battle against that which is going to battle against you.
because you're already promised the victory.
You already know death is defeated.
So why then would you fear?
Go to work, kill that which is seeking to kill you.
And you don't have to do it alone.
David tells us that you get to do it alongside friends, which is where he goes in verse five.
He says, let a righteous man strike me.
It's a kindness.
Let him rebuke me.
It's oil for my head.
Let my head not refuse it.
The third step David gives us for controlling our cravings is you have to find friends who will correct you.
You have to find friends who will correct you.
He tells us two really important things about combating our cravings in this passage.
He tells us, number one, you've got to find righteous friends.
And number two, they need to interact with you in a righteous sort of way.
When he says that they need to be righteous, what does that mean?
Righteousness in the Bible is equivalent to godliness, which we talk about a lot today.
So it isn't just someone that claims to know God, it's someone that is seeking to become like Him.
That doesn't just say they've been saved by Jesus, but is seeking to become like Him.
That's what you're looking for.
You're looking for someone that is serious about pursuing holiness.
Why do you want to find that?
Someone that wants to be separate from their sin.
Because if they're so serious about being separate from their sin, they're probably going to be helpful to helping you separate yourself from your own.
That makes sense.
When I showed up to Dallas, I did not have a barber.
I desperately needed to find someone to cut my hair.
And so what did I do?
I looked across all the land for the best head of hair I could find.
And when I found it, I asked that gentleman, where did he get your haircut?
And he told me where he got his haircut.
And that's now where I get my haircut to this day.
Why did I do that?
because there were signs of credibility in his life.
And thus, I gave him dignity to speak into mine.
Makes sense how that works.
We do this in every area of life.
You want to get fit.
You look to someone that's fit.
You want to get healthy.
You look to someone that's healthy.
You want to get smart.
You look to someone that's smart.
This is the way that we learn in life.
If you want to combat your sin, you're going to need people that are serious about doing that themselves.
He also tells us how we should interact.
He tells us that we should interact in a way that's characterized by two different words.
The first is he says they should strike him, which is a little off-putting.
Can we just admit that?
I don't know that I necessarily want a friend to strike me until you understand what the Hebrew means.
The Hebrew tells us that it's the idea of someone speaking with decisive impact.
So it would be the idea of when they speak, it's like they swing the hammer and thus they deal the blow.
That's what you want.
You want someone that when they speak, it makes a material difference in your life.
That's not the only thing though.
He says that he wants someone who will rebuke him, meaning someone that will gently admonish him or correct him.
You want someone that can do both of these things.
You see, you want people in your life who love you enough to tell you the things that you need to hear, not the things that you want to hear.
In the Bible, it authenticates this kind of friendship.
A few verses just so you can take my word for it.
Proverbs 27, 6 says faithful or trusted are the wounds of a friend, the profuse or the kisses of an enemy.
Proverbs 28, 23, whoever rebukes a man will afterward find more favor than he who flatters with his tongue.
And then Jesus even said this in Revelation 3, 19 at the end of all time, he said, those whom I love, I reprove and I discipline.
Isn't that interesting that that's what he says there?
I reprove them.
I discipline them.
I love them.
So be zealous and repent.
I know these types of friendships have been some of the greatest gifts in my life.
Like whenever I've been in seasons of particular hardship and thus struggle, my friends and I have come together and we have literally written questions.
We want the others to ask us.
Why do we do that?
Because nobody knows me better than me.
Minus my wife.
But I know myself really well.
I know where I go whenever I'm tempted.
I know what I do whenever I'm bored.
I know when I'm tired, what is my inclination?
I know myself.
And so rather than someone trying to ask any questions and investigate what's going on, what if I just handed them the appropriate list of questions to interrogate me thoroughly?
That would be the wisest thing for me to do.
That would be the wisest thing for all of us to do, to look to a friend that is again, godly, man, they are serious about pursuing Jesus and they're willing to speak
Honestly with you.
And so you give them the set of questions and you let them investigate your life.
You have some risky conversations that are going to leave you exposed.
Does it feel good to be exposed?
No.
But it is better to be exposed with a friend than safe in your sin.
So you find someone who wants to get into the thick of it with you.
You find
the godliest friends you can.
You hand them a list of questions, and you give them permission to ask you all of them at least once a week.
It'll be what David says.
It'll be the kindest thing they can do to you.
It'll be like oil on your head.
It'll be honoring to you for them to do these things.
Okay, last thing, let's keep going.
Verses 8 through 10.
David says, but my eyes are toward you, oh God, my Lord.
In you, I seek refuge.
Leave me not defenseless.
Keep me from the trap that they've laid for me, from the snares of evildoers.
Let the wicked fall into their own nets while I pass by safely.
The fourth and final step to controlling your cravings is you have to pursue intimacy with God.
You have to pursue intimacy with God.
By the end of this psalm,
David's circumstances are not changed.
Like he's not magically or miraculously pulled out of all the hardship that he's facing.
Instead, he is still in the midst of it.
But rather than be where he was at the beginning distracted by what everybody was doing, he's laser focused on what God is doing.
He has set his gaze.
I love the way it says, my eyes are toward you, O God.
In you, I seek refuge.
If you walk into a room and you see that what you want, you don't aimlessly move around.
You're filled with purpose.
And so you pursue wholeheartedly.
That's what he's saying.
Get your eyes on God.
And as you do so, he'll take care of all the traps and all the snares and all the nets.
What does it look like to get your eyes on God?
I love the way that Thomas Chalmers who wrote the explosive power of new affection.
He says this.
He says, the best way to overcome the world is not with morality and self-discipline.
Pull yourself up by your boot jokes.
No.
Christians overcome the world by seeing the beauty and the excellence of Christ.
They overcome the world by seeing something more attractive than the world.
So how do you see he who is most attractive of all?
How do you set your eyes and fix your gaze to behold his beauty?
I'll give you two ideas very quickly.
Number one is you avoid unnecessary temptation.
You avoid unnecessary temptation.
James 1 14 tells us, but each person is tempted when he's lured in enticed by his own desires.
I love the way that John Owen says it.
He says, no.
that he that dares to dally with occasions of sin will dare to sin.
What's that mean?
If you put yourself in a position to be tempted by sin, guess what's gonna happen?
You're gonna sin.
So avoid unnecessary temptation.
Like if the gem or his cubicle or
your run club or Netflix or your boyfriend's bedroom.
I don't know what it is.
Like if those places dare you to sin, if they tempt you to sin, don't go near them.
And if you're in a spot where it's like, but I can't avoid those situations.
I can't avoid those specific settings.
Then guess what?
You need to set some parameters.
You need to put some rules on your life.
You need to literally regulate your behavior.
You treat yourself like a child.
What do you do with children?
You tell them what they can and they cannot do and you hold them fast to it and you get some people around you that will hold you fast to it as well.
One of the best things that ever happened to me was a group of friends in my life.
They would ground me if ever I went against the parameters that I set.
Isn't that ridiculous?
How do you think you are?
You think you can ground me?
Yeah, man, you gave us permission too.
Fair enough.
You know, like you need some people that are willing to look at you, love you, and ground you from doing that what you should not do.
You need some people that are willing to go the distance when you're not willing to go.
You gotta avoid unnecessary temptation.
And secondly, you gotta pursue personal proximity.
Like you've got to take out the bad and you've got to replace it with good.
You got to seek Jesus.
And I know as I'm saying all this, you're like, wow, that's all very profound.
You don't need more complicated truth.
You just need to apply basic truth.
And basic truth says,
Get your eyes off the things that tempt you to sin and get your eyes on the one who has saved you from sin.
Pursue personal proximity.
That doesn't mean do a bunch of religious activity.
That means get close to Jesus.
Do the things that bring you near to Him.
David says in Psalm 27, four, one thing have I asked,
That will I seek, that I might gaze upon the beauty of the Lord, to enquire in His temple.
All David wants is to see Jesus in seek after him, because he knows there's no one like that man, there's no one
that there's no one that comes relatively close in comparison.
I have seen in my God that which cannot be seen anywhere else.
And so I'm gonna do everything in my power to get as close to him as I can.
For the sake of time,
I can't deeply unpack for you how you do that.
How do you get close to them?
You can take some guesses.
It's going to mean you're going to read the scripture, you're going to pray to God, you're going to confess your sin, you're going to get involved in community.
But if you want to unpack all that, we're going to have some people down front that would love to do it with you.
But there's nothing more important than this.
You pursue him because he pursued you.
Like when none of us trusted God, he trusted God.
He trusted God with his whole life.
When none of us could be justified in our sin, because we were all justifying our sin, he stepped into the story and he justified us of our sin anyways.
When all of us could not remain correct, he came.
And he walked correctly in this life.
And yet he died our death, absorbing into himself all the wrath of God intended for us.
And yet because he wanted intimacy with you and me, he burst forth from the grave.
He rose from the dead that any that would place every to him might have relationship with him forever.
Why do you pursue him?
Because he pursued you.
He came to save you from that, which you feel like you cannot be saved from.
He came to free you from that, which you feel so enslaved to.
He came to rescue you from that, which you feel like has reigned in your life for far too long.
Come to Him, place your faith in Him, and live a new life beginning tonight.
Let me pray that you would.
And Jesus, thank you for this evening,
Thank you, God, for these people.
Thank you, God, for your word.
Thank you, God, that this is real.
Gosh.
You and I have just been wrestling all day long.
that I don't God want the porch to be a place where we just do really good ministry, God.
No, I want the porch to be a place where there's power and there's impact and there's meaning and there's purpose, God.
I need the porch to be a place where the porch's name is not what's remembered, but it's Jesus' name that is remembered, God.
I want this to be a place where heaven touches down to earth, where we feel a transcendent collision, God, where the supernatural and natural collide into one.
We're Jesus, we get to behold you as you are, not as we think you to be, but as you are.
It's O God, police.
Let these next moments matter.
God, you could wash away the whole ministry.
You could take away all of the porch.
But I'm praying, God, you would save these people forever.
that you would give them eyes to see that which is most beautiful.
And you would do that starting now.
We sing to you, Jesus.
We need you, Jesus.
And we're going to respond to you, Jesus.
That's in your name we pray.
Amen.